Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 32. Und wir reden heute mal über den Kalten Krieg 2.0. So nennen wir das mal, was da gerade so passiert in der Ukraine zwischen dem Westen und Russland.
Ja, es tut uns leid, dass schon wieder so viel Zeit ins Land gegangen ist, aber uns sind leider einige Verhandlungen gescheitert mit irgendwelchen Gästen, coole Sendungen zu machen. Das ist ja mein Termin nicht ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man hochkarätige Gäste haben will.
Und selber so viel unterwegs ist.
So sieht es so aus. Und deswegen machen wir jetzt eine Sendung ohne Gast damit, wenn wir jetzt überhaupt mal vorankommen.
Genau, das ist ja auch nicht zu sehr langweilig. Der Kalte Krieg, einige werden sich noch erinnern, ist offiziell ja geendet quasi mit dem Fall der Mauer 1989. Also 1989 oder andere sagen halt auch so 1990 mit dem Zusammenbau der Sowjetunion. Also dem Ende des Ost-West-Konfliktes in seiner klassischen Ausprägung von USA versus Sowjetunion mit ihren jeweiligen Satellitenstaaten. Was wir so danach hatten, war ja so eine gewisse...
Na ja, warte mal, warte mal. Das kam ja schon, also bei uns kam das nicht an wie... Also ich West-Berlin, ja, ich bin hier der Wessi. Bei uns kam das nicht an wie Russen gegen Amis und Vassalen jeweils, sondern Russen gegen uns und die Amis helfen uns hoffentlich. Also das war schon ein sehr persönliches, direktes Bedrohungsgefühl im Westen zumindest. Gut, jetzt wahrscheinlich Berlin besonders, aber...
Also wir fühlten uns eigentlich immer mehr so von den Amis bedroht. Von Westdeutschland fühlt man uns eigentlich nicht so sehr bedroht.
Nee, aber das Bild bei uns war weniger, dass wir der Vasalle sind, der bedroht wird, weil es eigentlich gegen die Amis geht, sondern wir waren das Ziel. So das war unsere und unser Weltbild jedenfalls. Wir sind das Ziel und unsere Freunde in Amerika helfen uns. Ja, also die gegnerische Seite haben wir zwar als Blog wahrgenommen. Das lag ja auch an den Grenzübergängen. Das war ja schon schwierig.
Die Erfahrung war ein bisschen unmittelbarer. Also ihr hattet ja sozusagen eine unmittelbare Erfahrung mit der DDR.
Genau, also wir haben den Ostblog schon als Blog wahrgenommen. Das hieß auch immer Ostblog bei uns oder Warschauer Pakt. Was ich ja erst in den letzten Jahren gelernt habe, dass das im Osten gar nicht Warschauer Pakt hieß, sondern Warschauer Vertrag. Das war reine Propaganda, dass wir das im Westen Pakt genannt haben, weil es schön fies und gemeinklingend ist.
Pakt klingt so wie Verschwörung zur Ausgradierung des Westens oder so.
Das klingt irgendwie unseriös, als wenn man da fiese und gemeine...
Ja, so einen Pakt schließt man so um, naja, schon so was mit Gewalt durchzusetzen oder so.
Ja, so ein Halunkenpakt. Ich weiß nicht irgendwie, das war immer negativ belegt. Dass es im Wesentlichen dasselbe ist wie die NATO, das war, auf die Idee bin ich gar nicht gekommen im Kalten Krieg. Ja, also die NATO war so, wir helfen uns gegenseitig, ja, die Demokratien unterstützen sich gegenseitig, das war was Positives, ja, gegenseitiges Helfen und zu Hilfe eilen in der Not und der Warschauer Pakt, das war so ein Geklüngel aus fiesen und gemeinen Angriffsländern, die sich dann irgendwie gegenseitig helfen, wenn einer von ihnen auf frischer Tat ertappt wird oder so.
Im Osten war die NATO, da waren halt so die Ami-Vasallen, die denen halt dabei helfen, den Weltfrieden zu gefährden.
Das stimmt ja auch.
In gewisser Art war es ja nicht so weit, wenn man von der Wahrheit entspannt. Aber die Wahrnehmung der NATO war halt eine bedrohliche. Das waren halt die mit den Raketen, das sind schon diese Pershing-2-Mittelstrecken-Raketen, weswegen wir halt leider SS-20 nachrüsten mussten.
Also ich bin ja im Nachhinein wirklich erstaunt, wie wenig das eine Rolle gespielt hat, dass Frankreich aus der NATO ausgetreten ist. Das war doch im Grunde der Beweis, dass das überhaupt nicht notwendig ist, in der NATO zu sein. Also jetzt vielleicht nicht für Deutschland, weil wir nur direkt an der Front waren, aber für die ganzen anderen Länder war das doch der Nachweis, dass es nicht alternativlos ist, in der NATO zu sein. Aber das ist ja überhaupt kein Thema gewesen, so im Diskurs, in der Politik. Warum sind wir eigentlich in der NATO? Überhaupt nicht. Die Frage wurde überhaupt nicht gestellt. Ja gut, wir waren jetzt noch nicht souverän, aber auch die anderen Länder.
Also richtig souverän waren die ja auch nicht. Ich meine Großbritannien war nicht souverän.
Da muss man schon sagen, Hut ab an die Franzosen, dass sie das mal eben gemacht haben damals war. Das war ja auch für die. Die waren ja auch echt am Ende. Das war also schon auch keine einfache Sache, das Innenpolitis zu verkaufen.
Habt ihr eigentlich im Westen Ostpropaganda mitbekommen?
So gut wie gar nicht. Also die ganzen Sachen, die ich gelernt habe, waren alle nach dem Kalten Krieg. Also die diesen Nummernsender, die uns da im Harz gegeben, die sind diesen Verarschungssender, der irgendwelche komischen...
Die sind Soldatensender und so.
Ja, ja, diese ganzen Sachen hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt. Ich hab aber auch überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt. Also das ist auch so eine unkritische Situation, in der ich aufgewachsen bin. Ich hab die viele Sachen einfach so nicht hinterfragt, weil ich die überhaupt nicht anders kannte. Ja, dass Rias ein US-Propagandasender war, war mir überhaupt nicht bewusst. Also ich wusste zwar, wofür es steht, aber dachte, naja, das ist halt der amerikanische Sektor. Dass die mit Regierungsmitteln bezahlt worden sind und um möglichst weit im Osten irgendwie das Gefühl von Freiheit und Malbürowerbung unterzubringen, das ist mir erst aufgefallen, als nach dem Kalten Krieg plötzlich die Kohle weg war und Rias im Radio anfing das zu thematisieren, das sie möglicherweise bald zumachen müssen. Und dann dachte ich so, was?
Ich meine, Rias war ja schon durchaus erfolgreich, weil die ja nicht sehr offensiv waren.
Weil die nicht so plump waren.
Genau, die waren nicht plump, sondern es gab halt schon so ein paar plumpe Sachen bei denen, also so ein paar Kommentatoren und einige Sachen in den Nachrichten waren, also stießen einem so auch im Osten schon unangenehm auf, aber die waren halt einfach die mit der coolen Musik so damals.
Genau, die gibt es auch. Die Plumpenleute gibt es ja auch in der FAZ. Also den Teil Ostpropaganda, den ich mitgekriegt habe, war der Schwarze Kanal. Das war so der Running Gag im Westen. Da haben wir uns immer tot gelacht über den Schmuddeleder. Wie hieß der? Ich hab den noch nicht mehr vergessen.
Sudeleeder. Sudeleeder, genau. War glaube ich bei euch der Sudeleeder. Den hat im Osten niemand geguckt.
Na ja, auch im Westen hat den so gut wie niemand geguckt, aber das war halt so. Das war halt so, ich weiß nicht, das ist ja heutzutage programmiert man ja seine Fernseher und kann die Kanäle umstellen. Das war ja irgendwie damals nicht so. Da konnte man zwar auch irgendwie tunen und so, aber du hast halt im Wesentlichen deine sieben oder was Kanäle gehabt.
Also fünf hat man ja, oder sechs, ja.
Also jetzt mit Privatfernsehen sind es dann mehr geworden. Aber so, da war halt irgendwie der Ostkanal. Da hinten hat da keiner einprogrammiert, sondern der war da halt. Du hast irgendwie das Ding gekauft und dann war da der Ostkanal. Und dann hast du halt, also man musste auch noch hinlaufen zum Fernseher am Anfang, um den Kanal zu wechseln. Und ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand jemals Ostfernsehen in seinen Fernseher einprogrammiert hat, sondern es war halt da. Und da ist man dann gelegentlich auch mal hängen geblieben. Und ich habe also nicht bewusst Ostfernsehen gesehen, weil da irgendwie nie Sachen liefen.
Also Sandmännchen war wohl ziemlich beliebt.
Das Sandmännchen war sehr beliebt, aber wir haben dann auch ein Sandmännchen gekriegt.
Aber das sah halt total pseudo aus.
SFB, das war auch total pseudo, aber es war in Farbe. Und im Osten war anfangs nicht in Farbe.
Na, wir hatten eine andere Farbfernsehen.
Genau, das war noch das Problem.
Genau, wir hatten ja Seekam, die französische Farbfernsehen.
Ich weiß noch, wenn du mal schlechten Empfang hattest, musst du noch eine aufs Dach klettern und dann eine Antenne drehen und so. Und dann hast du halt die Prioritäten nicht so gelegt, dass das Ostfernsehen gut aussah. Das Sandmännchen war wohl ganz beliebt, aber das haben wir, glaube ich, nicht gesehen, weil die haben so komische Akzente gehabt. Das war so nicht sächsisch, aber es war halt so Ostberlinerisch. Und das ist eine Sache, die ist mir wirklich aufgefallen, als die Mauer fiel, dass dieses Berlinerische, das gab es in Westberlin viel weniger als in Ostberlin. Also ich hab mal so ein paar Jahre in Westdeutschland mich zur Schule gegangen und das war so eine ganz lustige Szene, als ich da reinkam in den Klassenraum, die guckten mich alle an und erwarteten, dass ich da jetzt in einer völlig unverständlichen Mundart losrede. Und das war halt nicht der Fall. Ich hab halt Deutsch gesprochen, Hochdeutsch. Aber Ostberlin, die haben, ich will nicht sagen, das zelebriert ihre Mundart. Aber das war deutlich ausgeprägter als im Westen in den Klassen.
Ich glaube, es hat damit zu tun gehabt, dass die, also das hat man so als Berlinerisch bezeichnet ja durchaus auch, der Dialekt des Brandenburger Raums, also was heute Brandenburg ist, um Berlin drum herum ist. Also da wurde das ja auch noch relativ stark gesprochen. Das ist ja durchaus, aber interessant, dass du meinst, das Sandmännchen, das Ostberliner Sandmännchen, hat ja einen Dialekt, das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ja, die, ich weiß nicht, das gibt so ein, also das sind so die Erinnerungen aus meiner Kindheit irgendwie. Nur das hat so deutlich gemerkt, ob du gerade beim Ost- oder Westsandmännchen warst, weil die klang einfach anders. Aber also ich erinnere mich auch daran, Ostfernsehen in Farbe gesehen zu haben, aber das war immer irgendwie blass, weil diese Farbnorm war scheiße.
Naja, sie kamen halt nicht so richtig.
Aber unabhängig davon, also ich erinnere mich daran, dass es im Osten Propaganda gab, aber die klangen einfach wie Propaganda. Die klangen einfach so, als wenn mir da gerade einer... Das war so, na das war nicht nur nicht gut, sondern das war so ein predigender Stil, weißt du, von einem Typ, der dir jetzt die Wahrheit erzählt und felsenfest davon überzeugt ist, dass er mit mir gar nicht zuhören muss, weil er die Fakten alle schon hat. Dieses Gefühl, dass da einer von der Kanzel runter predigt, das weckt instinktiv schon mal so ein Gefühl so, passt das denn, das muss ich mir jetzt nicht anhören. Und Sudeleede war halt so, der hat so zwei, drei Sachen erzählt, mir ist da jetzt nichts konkret in den Ohren geblieben, aber wo ich schon den Eindruck hätte, na das wär ja krass, wenn es stimmt. Aber man ist ihm halt nicht hinterher gestiegen dann im Westen.
Das Interessante daran war aber, dass die Perspektive über den Westen, die er vermittelt hat anhand von westlichen Medienausschnitten, das war ja auch immer so sein Stil, so halt irgendwie die Media Snippets aus dem Westfernsehen zu nehmen und die dann zu kommentieren beziehungsweise so zurechtzuschneiden, dass der Kontext fehlt, dass man sie besser kommentieren konnte und so. Aber das Bild, das da rüberkam, war so im Westen, eigentlich klebt schon so die Hälfte der Bevölkerung auf der Straße und ist arbeitslos. Eigentlich ist alles so kurz vorm Zusammenbrechen, also der Sicht des Sozialismus ist eigentlich nicht aufzuhalten, weil der Westen klappt sowieso in sich zusammen und obendrein lügt er. Und das Interessante daran war, dass viele von diesen Details, die er sich da rausgepickt hat, über, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Nicaragua oder internationale Ereignisse, da haben wir im Osten die Westpropaganda eigentlich nur so am Rande wahrgenommen. So, weil das war halt so, naja, das hat uns eigentlich nicht so interessiert. Das war so weit weg.
Also ihr habt eigentlich das Entertainment mitgenommen aus den Westmedien, aber den Rest ignoriert?
Nein, nicht wirklich ignoriert. Das hat natürlich einen Einfluss auf dich. Wenn du halt irgendwie die Nachrichten hörst, dann hörst du die Nachrichten. Das hatte natürlich einen Einfluss auf dich. Das war ja auch das Prinzip dabei. Das kann man auch nicht leugnen, dass das dich in einer Art und Weise beeinflusst oder dir zumindest eine andere Perspektive gibt. Insbesondere noch, weil die Ostnachrichten halt an vielen Stellen halt auch einfach offensichtlich auslassend und verfälschend waren. Gerade auch über Ereignisse, die halt... Also eigentlich am interessantesten waren die Westnachrichten über Ereignisse im Osten. Also die Sachen, die sie uns nicht erzählt haben oder von denen wir das Gefühl hatten, dass sie uns die nicht erzählt haben. Also gerade so Tschernobyl zum Beispiel oder sowas.
Aber das war echt selten eigentlich, oder? Also das war nicht mein Eindruck, dass sie im Westen ständig über den Osten erzählt haben.
Nee, nicht ständig, nee. Aber das waren die interessantesten Nachrichten.
Das Deutlichste fand ich immer, diese die Karten, die Landkarten, die sie gezeigt haben. Das fand ich immer das Deutlichste Propaganda. Zumindest jetzt ist mir damals nicht als Propaganda aufgefallen. Aber rückblickend hast du ja immer Deutschland gezeigt und dann hast du die Landkarte und der Westteil hat eine hervorgehobene Farbe. Und das ist eigentlich eine Trennung, die wir inhaltlich immer zumindest so taten, als wollten wir die gar nicht. Aber wir haben doch visuell für eine Trennung gesorgt, wann immer es irgendwo eine Landkarte gab. Und dann immer der kleine Fleck Westberlin war ja auch immer noch speziell hervorgehoben. Ja ach naja, aber also das war so die Propaganda-Sachen, an die ich mich erinnere. Aber so die ganzen krassen Dinge habe ich erst nachher gehört. Also es gab da mal eine Dokumentation über einen Mordfall im Osten. Und eigentlich gab es keine Morde, so laut Staats-Selbstbild. Bei uns gibt es keine Morde und deswegen haben sie das halt aus den Nachrichten fern gehalten und mussten dann aber irgendwie über einen größeren Landstrich Verdächtige isolieren oder so. Und hatten ein Problem, wie sie die Leute jetzt ansprechen sollen, wenn sie nicht in Nachrichten erwähnen dürfen, dass es da jetzt irgendwas gab. Also diese Art von Detail habe ich alle erst nach dem Mauerfall erlebt. Und ich muss sagen, wir haben hier in der Vorbereitung das schon kurz angesprochen, aus meiner Sicht, diese ganze Propaganda war zwar sehr ähnlich in den beiden Ländern, vor dem jeweils anderen Land, aber es gab doch Unterschiede. Also die Angst im Westen war, der Russe ist irgendwie überall mit seinen Spionen und hört mit und klaut alles, der klaut uns hier unsere Technologie. Die haben ihre Raumfahrtsachen, haben die alle von den Amis geklaut, die Atombomben haben sie von den Amis geklaut. Das war so das Bild im Westen. Also nicht irgendwie, ich fühlte mich nicht bedroht im Sinne von morgen machen die eine Atombombe auf uns, sondern das Bild war eher, das wäre dann irgendwie ein Missverständnis, wenn sie glauben, sie werden angegriffen oder so. Oder der Westen glaubt, er wird angegriffen. Irgendwie so geht ein Krieg los. Also das Bild in West-Berlin zumindest in meiner Erfahrung war nicht, die wollen uns angreifen. Und ich glaube, dass dieses Bild von wegen, wir müssen Angst haben vor dem Osten, wäre sofort in sich selbst zusammengefallen, wenn mehr Wessis mal in Osten gefahren wären. Das konnte man ja in Berlin relativ stressarm machen. Also man brauchte irgendwie ein paar Monate Vorlauf, wenn man da irgendwie durch das normale Programm wollte. Aber im Grunde konnte man da reinfahren und dann konnte man da rumfahren und dann konnte man wieder rausfahren. Ist ja nun andersrum schwieriger gewesen, wenn man nicht gauk hieß. Aber ich hab das mal gemacht als Kind, saß ich hinten im Auto und hab das als sehr beklemmt wahrgenommen im Osten, weil da gab es keine Straßenleuchten. Wir fuhren so durch Ost-Berlin durch, und um den Alexanderplatz herum gab es sogar Werbung. Sonst nirgendswo Werbung. Wenn man mal einen Laden sah mit Auslage, dann war das nie irgendwie so werbend. Hier kauft da, ist cool. Sondern so einfach darstellend.
Also dieses, wir haben das jetzt hier.
Wir haben das jetzt, ja. Aber das war so, das ist eine Sache, da hab ich, konnte ich gar nicht so den Finger drauflegen am Anfang, was es jetzt genau ist, was hier anders ist. Aber wenn es überhaupt keine Werbung gibt im Straßenbild, das war irgendwie was sehr Beklemmendes für mich, weil es einfach fremd war. Und um den Alex herum gab es aber Werbung und es gab Straßenlaternen und es gab beleuchtete Häuser. Das heißt, da war so das Gefühl, ist ja wie bei uns, ja. Aber wenn man dann auf dem Rückweg vom Alex irgendwie zum Grenzübergang, irgendwie zwei Straßen weiter, sah das aus wie so Bruch, ja. Das fällt hier alles in sich zusammen. Und wenn man das mal gesehen hat, dann fällt diese Gefahr, dieses Gefühl der Gefahr weg. Morgen kommen die und marschieren bei uns ein. Die können ja nicht mal ihre eigenen Häuser irgendwie hier. Also dieses Bedrohungsgefühl hätte man beenden können. Und ich glaube, da hat der Osten einfach die Zeichen der Zeit verkackt, indem sie da diesen Zwangsumtausch und diese Monate vor irgendwie Prüfung und alles irgendwie so beantragen. Wenn sie das nicht gemacht hätten und die Leute einfach eingeladen hätten, hier, komm doch mal gucken. Also nicht, dass man irgendwie als Wessi gesagt hätte, boah, es ist cool hier, ich tret jetzt im Kommunismus bei. Aber dieses Gefühl, die warten nur darauf, bei uns einmarschieren zu können, wäre halt weg gewesen.
Ich denke, der Osten ist einfach Opfer seiner eigenen Propaganda geworden da, weil er immer davon ausging, dass eigentlich alles aus dem Westen ferngesteuert wird. Also auch all die jegliche Oppositionsbewegungen, alles was irgendwie schief lief, war eigentlich immer westliche Sabotage von westlichen Agenten ferngesteuert. Also eigentlich, weil konnte ja nicht anders sein im Wesentlichen. Also gab ja keine indigenen Bösebolde, sondern wenn, dann waren die halt vom Westen ferngesteuert oder kompromittiert worden. Also dass sie erpresst oder bestochen waren. Das war eigentlich so der...
Und haben die Leute das geglaubt oder war das so das Bild von oben?
Das war so das Bild von oben. Es hat eigentlich niemand wirklich so... Dachten sich, warum sollte der Westen das denn tun? Ja, war so eigentlich eher so die so... Interessanter war, es gab's natürlich, ja. Es war ja nicht so, dass sie es nicht versucht haben.
Sie haben es versucht, aber sie sind ja doch irgendwie großflächig gescheitert, wenn man so die Geschichten aus Kuba zumindest hört.
Ja, es gab's natürlich im Osten auch, aber die Leute, die wirklich relativ effiziente, die der Opposition unterstützt haben, waren halt nicht so die CAA-Leute oder so. Sondern es waren halt Leute, die es halt so eher aus, sagen wir, ideologischen Gründen gemacht haben, wie die Grünen zum Beispiel, die halt dann der Opposition tatsächlich praktisch geholfen haben mit den Sachen, die wirklich fehlten und zwar denen, den Leuten...
Klopapier geschickt?
Nöner Computer und Schreibmaschinen und so. Also dieses CIA-Nummer war aber immer und überall so. Also eigentlich war eigentlich alles immer von Agenten bedroht so und das war auch das...
Das war auch bei uns das Bild, aber halt anders. Nicht so die wollen kaputt machen. Also aber bei uns war das nicht so Propaganda, sondern halt Hollywood-Filme. Also in der so 60er, 70er, frühe 80er, da gab es Berlin und Wien galten als Hochbogen des internationalen Agententums und es gab so Thriller und es gab sogar mal ein Dieter Haller-Forten-Film, wo er irgendwie einen Taxifahrer spielt, der irgendwie in irgendwelche Agenten-Intrigen verwickelt wird. Also das war, von daher wirkte es so, als sei das irgendwie ein wichtiger Teil des Lebens. Also jetzt hat mich nie persönlich irgendwie betroffen, aber von dem, was du so in den Filmen gesehen hast, sagst du, die müssen ja überall sein. Und drückblickend hört man ja tatsächlich Geschichten. Dass sie sich also bemüht haben, ja. Aber es hat eigentlich niemanden so persönlich betroffen.
Wenn man sich das so anguckt, dann gab es ja so ein paar Propaganda-Werkzeuge, die relativ effizient waren. Das war halt sowas wie zum Beispiel Helldrias oder Voice of America und ähnliche Sender. Und die der Osten einfach nie hinbekommen hat, weil sie nie cool waren. Also sie hatten halt nie die Lockerheit zu sagen, okay, wir können jetzt mal die Wahrheit berichten und die nur so ein bisschen verdrehen, so wie es halt gerade notwendig ist.
Da mussten sie ja auch nicht, oder?
Nee, ich meine, jetzt...
Spielt das noch Richtung Westen?
Nee, Richtung Westen. Also sozusagen für die eigene Bevölkerung. Gut, da hatten sie halt eh verkackt, weil das war halt so dermaßen ritualisiert und klammsied, hat niemand gelesen. Das neue Deutschland hat man irgendwie abonniert, wenn man irgendwie belegen wollte, dass man ein guter Genosse war und keinen Straß irgendwie auf Arbeit haben wollte, aber das gelesen hat wirklich fast niemand. Und wenn, dann musstest du halt zwischendurch den Zeilen lesen, oder hast mal einen Lokalteil gelesen oder so. Da gab es halt noch so die Berliner Zeitung, die war halt so... Naja, da gab es halt wenigstens so lokalen Berlin-Teilen, die eben auch nochmal so echte Nachrichten standen und so. Aber so der typische DDR-Zeitungslese hat also vorne so die ersten...
Den Politik-Teil?
Zehn, zwölf Seiten so, den hast du nicht mal angeguckt, nicht mal aufgeblättert hast du vielleicht. Das macht man ja heute immer noch so, wenn man Politik und Wirtschaft beiseite legt, dass man in der Furchtung und Reisen ankommt. So ähnlich wie man heute die FAZ liest, hat man damals irgendwie die DDR-Zeitung gelesen, genau. Und die, also die, sag mal, die nach innen gerichtete Propaganda hatte auch viel mit so einfach nur dem Versuch, des Überwindens der Lethargie zu tun. Also die waren halt, es waren halt viele Leute, die hatten das einfach wirklich nicht mehr interessiert. Das war halt, die haben das, das fand das völlig irrelevant. Weil das hatte mit ihrem Alltag nichts zu tun und die wollten davon einfach nur nicht belästigt werden. So und die haben dann halt die Nachrichten gehört, die mit der fluffigen Musik kamen, also halt irgendwie ums Afförias oder was auch immer ging.
Ja, also mein Eindruck war ja, dass Hollywood eigentlich der größte Propaganda, starker Arm der Amerikaner war.
Für den Westen?
Ja. Also nicht nur für den Westen, auch.
Im Norden Osten gab es die Filme eigentlich nicht, also nur im Fernsehen halt. Naja, stimmt ja im Fernsehen.
Aber dieses Bild von wegen, also Roadmovies zum Beispiel sehr beliebt und Western, die überhaupt nichts mit dem Alltag zu tun haben, sehr beliebt einfach irgendwelche Leute zu beobachten, wie sie endlos in Amerika irgendwelche Straßen langfahren. Das ist einfach diese diese Sehnsucht nach grenzenloser Freiheit und dem amerikanischen Traum. Ich glaube, das war hauptsächlich Hollywood. Denn wenn man, wenn man also ich habe mehr Ostfernsehen geguckt, als ich Voice of America gehört habe. Das habe ich nie gehört. Nie. Also überhaupt nicht. Ich hätte es gekonnt natürlich. Aber wenn, wenn ich weiß, das ist irgendwie Propagandascheiß. Warum würde ich denn überhaupt jemals hingucken? Also beim Osten kannst du dich ja wenigstens noch lustig machen drüber, wenn du sagst, das ist irgendwie der politische Gegner. Haha, da falle ich jetzt nicht drauf rein. Aber seine eigene Propaganda will man noch gar nicht hören.
Nee, stimmt.
Und kennst du jemanden, der Voice of America gehört hat?
Ich hab tatsächlich Voice of America gehört.
Echt? Erzähl mal, was haben die denn da so gemacht?
Die waren halt so ein bisschen dröge. Also die hatten halt so einen gewissen, na sozusagen die schlechten Seiten vom Deutschlandfunk waren, also so die Seiten, die halt irgendwie nicht so, meine, was halt cooler war, war halt, wie hießen die? AFCN oder so?
Ach dieser, dieser Militärfunk?
Weil die hatten halt immer die coolste Mucke.
Also das Lustige ist ja auch, dass die freigestellt waren von irgendwelchen Lizenzzahlungen. Deswegen kamen die teilweise an die Songs ran, bevor es die eigentlich immer hier gab.
Die gab es halt richtig.
Und das war natürlich auch für uns was Besonderes. Andersrum war es aber so, dass der der Osten auch irgendwie Radio in Richtung Westen gemacht hat, mit irgendwie Raubkopien von Songs, die sie irgendwie über die Grenze geschmuggelt haben. Also das war schon immer so dieser Kulturexport. Dieser, das war schon immer eine starke Waffe. Wenn du einfach der der anderen Seite zeigst, was ja mal so cool ist bei uns, wollt ihr das nicht auch?
Aber das interessante daran war, dass die haben halt einfach nie im Osten das hinbekommen. Also es war nie cool. Da gab es halt nichts so.
Na das ist halt, wenn du was aus Überzeugung machst, dann hast du immer dieses kanzelhafte Predigen an dir.
Nee, aber die hatten einfach natürlich keine... Also meine Musik im Osten war ja zu kotzen. Na also da gab es ja nichts. Also die einzigen interessanten Bands, die es gab, waren halt so ein oder zwei so. Also die jetzt so offiziell groß waren. Und dann der Rest war halt irgendwie, kam halt erst in den 80er Jahren, als halt irgendwie sowas ähnliches wie Garage-Punk anfingen und halt so ein bisschen Elektronik und so. Die quasi völlig nicht kommerziell erst mal angefangen haben einfach nur Musik zu machen. Das war halt eigentlich auch die Musik, die sagen wir mal eine gewisse Ost-Identität hatte in dem Sinne. Also war sie, also weil das offizielle Zeug war halt so scheiße so. Und war halt so Karat und Pudis und so. Das waren noch so die besten Sachen davon. Das ging noch so und dann danach ging es halt rapide abwärts. Ein paar sind auch von den Pudis und der wirklich gut, aber ja. Also ich sag mal so, das war halt so die Spitze des Eisberges und danach war halt irgendwie schon Schluss und die, ja es gab halt kein Vehikel zum Transporterpropagand an den Westen. Deswegen haben die ja viel gemacht halt mit so Unterwanderung und irgendwie Leuten, die halt diese korruptiert haben, Journalisten, die sie erpresst haben, um so Stories zu platzieren und so. Und das war ja auch so die große Sorge, die der Westen so hatte, so dass sie halt immer versucht haben rauszufinden, welche Journalisten geben sich denn zu viel mit irgendwelchen kommunistennahen oder sozialdemokratennahen Organisationen ab oder bekommen woher Geld und so. Da ist ja nach der Wende auch ein bisschen was rausgekommen, dass es da einige Leute gab. Aber interessanterweise fand das umgekehrt ja nie statt. Also es war, wie viele Journalisten in Westdeutschland von den Amis tatsächlich bezahlt wurden und heute ja immer noch irgendwie gut und gerne in Kooptierung genommen werden.
Musst sie auch nicht bezahlen. Die gehen ja freiwillig in die Atlantikbrücke. Aber lustigerweise gab es ja ein CAA-Programm, um so abstrakte Kunst zu fördern.
Mit Tiergeld. Die haben tatsächlich Bilder gekauft, Kindgalerien betrieben und den Jungs und Mädels Drogen gekauft, die sie in Partys veranstaltet.
Einfach nur, damit sie zeigen können, guck mal bei uns gibt es Freiheit der Kunst. Lustigerweise hat es, was man so hört, den CA-Leuten auch überhaupt nicht gefallen. Sondern es ging tatsächlich nur darum, reine Propaganda ist eigentlich schon abgefahren. Also ich finde, aus meiner Einstellung hier, würde ich sagen, wenn dein System es nötig hat, fremde Propaganda zu enttarnen und gegenzuwirken, dann ist es kein verteidigenswertes System. Das muss von sich aus besser sein. Egal, was die Propaganda erzählt. Wenn dein System, wenn der Vorsprung so knapp ist, dass du dir Sorgen machen musst, dass die gegnerische Seite irgendwie drei, vier Journalisten bezahlt, damit sie böse Sachen über dich schreiben, dann sollst du vielleicht tatsächlich aufgeben. Was soll denn das? So ein Scheiß. Naja, aber wir sind ja lustiger, wir warten immer noch in so einer Situation. Eigentlich wollten wir ja über die aktuelle Situation mehr reden, weniger.
Ich finde es interessant als Einstieg in genau die aktuelle Situation, dass wir uns ja wieder in so einer Art kalten Krieg bewegen, zumindest was die Propaganda angeht. Nur, dass sich mittlerweile eigentlich die Vorzeichen umgedreht haben. Putin hat halt, bzw. die Sowjetunion, hat ja doch strategisch ziemlich aufgerüstet.
Und man konnte das richtig beobachten. Also beim Georgischen Krieg, wenn du dich daran noch erinnerst.
Also 2004, 2005 ging es los.
Da war viel, viel weniger. Aber man hat schon gemerkt, da wird jetzt investiert.
Genau, die fangen jetzt an damit. Und die haben dann mit Russia Today und Andrea Novosti es tatsächlich geschafft, sich ein durchaus veritables Gegenmodell zu schaffen. Also eigentlich waren die ersten Al-Jazeera, die damit angefangen haben zu sagen, okay, wir wollen halt den amerikanischen Informationssenderdominanz was entgegensetzen, insbesondere halt irgendwie beim Irakkrieg und so. Und das halt irgendwie als Regierungssender betreiben. Und Russia Today ist halt...
Wobei, das ist ja immer der Angriffspunkt der Amerikaner gegen Al-Jazeera. Warum sie sagen, das muss man nicht dulden. Weil die von der Regierung von Katar bezahlt werden. Was ich sehr witzig finde, denn wenn man sich anguckt, wer in Amerika die ganzen Nachrichten bezahlt, die sind auch alle nicht unabhängig, sondern die gehören halt irgendwelchen Konzernen.
Na ja, gut.
Sowas wie GE und die sind natürlich abhängig von Regierungsaufträgen. Also das ist hüben wie drüben.
Na nicht nur das, sondern die Amerikaner haben ja auch sowas wie West of America, Radio Free Europe, Radio Free Asia und so weiter, die ja direkt von der Regierung bezahlt werden. Da gibt es ja dieses US Governments Broadcasting Board of Governors.
Auch im Iran übrigens eine Fasih-Station.
Und die haben, 2010 hat der Chef von diesem Board, der was halt die amerikanischen Auslandsländer sind, hat gesagt so, We cannot allow ourselves to be out-communicated by our enemies. Also wir können nicht out-communicated übersetzen, mal das.
Können die uns nicht schlagen lassen im Kommunikationsfall.
Er erzählt damals halt spezifisch von Russia Today, iranische Fernsehen, was mittlerweile noch nicht mehr so wichtig ist, glaube ich, unter den Chinesen.
Aber sagt es nicht. Also PressTV, ja, das ist durchaus so, dass sie das immer wieder schaffen, also so, weiß ich nicht, alle zwei Wochen mal schaffen die das so eine Story auch in die westliche Blogosphäre zu pushen.
Okay.
Also jetzt nicht irgendwie die meisten Sachen interessieren ja auch im Westen niemanden, aber so zwei, drei Sachen schon. Häufiger stellt sich dann raus, dass sie auf irgendeinen Hoax reingefallen sind oder so. Aber es ist nicht so, dass die völlig weg vom Keine Relevanz haben. Der dritte im Bunde, den die explizit erwähnen, ist China Central Television von den Chinesen, eine Station von der ich persönlich jetzt noch nichts gehört habe. Kennst du die?
Ja, also gerade so für Arsene Reporting ist die durchaus wesentlich.
Ist die Regierungsberatung mit ihm?
Okay. Das schöne Kürzel CCTV, was im Westen ist. Das Kürzel für Überwachungskameras, Close Circuit TV. Wir haben vielleicht nicht so gut drüber nachgedacht.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch mal kurz sagen, Voice of America haben wir schon erwähnt, Radio Free Europe ist der andere und es gibt Radio Free Asia.
Da gibt es noch so mehr, so kleinere Nischen.
Und ja, aber dieses Radio Free Europe finde ich bezeichnend, weil das ist auch eine Sache, die mir erst viel später aufgefallen ist. Das Sender Freies Berlin ist natürlich genau da eine Anlehnung dran. Dieser Name und deswegen heißt auch, dass die Zusammenführung mit Brandenburg dann lieber nach der brandenburgischen Version und nicht nach SFB, weil das ein warkalter Krieg, peinlich, Propagandascheiße ist der Name.
Ja, das stimmt.
Naja, aber das ist so typisch amerikanisch, dass sie dann gleich in den Titel reinschreiben, hier geht es um Free Europe.
Naja, es kommt aus einer langen Tradition. Also halt auch so die westlichen Rundfunksinnahmen zu Zeiten des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Ja, aber es ist ganz lustig zu sehen, wie die Herangehensweisen einfach anders sind. Also bei den Amerikanern ist es so, dass die dann ein Buch rausgeben, wo drauf steht, hier geht es um bla bla. Also die behaupten einfach mit dem Titel, sagen sie schonmal, worum es geht. Und das wird dann aber auch nicht mehr hinterfragt. Also so eine uraamerikanische Sache, auch Firmen machen das auch in Amerika.
Die sind aber auch mit so einem Pathos, wie, weiß nicht, wie das war, wie ist denn immer, eine freie Stimme der freien Welt.
Ja, ja, genau.
So einer dieser Slogans von so einem Radiosender. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welcher das war.
Das war glaube ich Radio Free Room.
Kann sein, ja. Aber dieses Pathos, was da drinsteckte, hatte ja durchaus einen gewissen Effekt. Also aus Sicht des Ostens war das halt so permanentes Salz in die Wunden streuen. Also am heftigsten fand ich ja immer so die, wer war das? Ich glaube das war Voice of America oder Radio Free Room. Einst von beiden, die haben immer Reiseberichte gebracht. Das war super interessant.
Guck mal, wie schön das da ist. Da kann man einfach hinfahren.
Rass, Rass, Rass. Genau so. Weißt du, wenn du das hörst, denkst du so.
Naja, aber ich finde, das kann man in Amerika generell beobachten. Die sind einfach so drauf, dass sie auch sagen, irgendwie das ist die Firma, die macht jetzt, die macht glaubwürdige Fernsehunterhaltung. Zum Beispiel. Also da würde in Deutschland keiner drauf kommen, irgendwie in den Titel reinzuschreiben, dass du glaubwürdig bist. Das ist so eine Sache. Das machen die Amerikaner einfach, die postulieren es einfach. Hier geht es um Free Europe. Und das ist eine andere Herangehensweise an Propaganda. Die Russen in ihrer Propaganda machen das eigentlich jetzt andersrum. Die lassen den, die Amerikaner vorgeben, worum es geht und drehen dann aber die Sache um. Also das ist nur die...
Die thematisieren auch... Also meine RT hat ja mehrere interessante Strategien. Also einer davon ist halt immer den Westen bei seinen eigenen Standards packen. Also den sozusagen die postulierten Werte und Standards.
Genau, aber die kommen halt von der Gegenseite. Während die Amerikaner sehr erpicht drauf sind, selber das Framing zu setzen.
Genau, aber die Effizienz von Russia Today zum Beispiel liegt ja auch daran, dass sie, insbesondere wenn sie aus den USA berichten, berichten sie halt eine Menge Sachen, die in den USA sonst unter den Tisch fallen. Also zum Beispiel diese Geschichte, dass sie in Detroit gerade der halben Bevölkerung das Wasser abdrehen. Also die halt ja eigentlich nur erstmal in der Blogosphäre stattfanden, dann auf RT und dann erst in die großen Medien kamen. Noch viel mehr solche Geschichten, also Geschichten über Polizeigewalt und Kriminalität.
Auch diese Hypothekengeschichte haben die wirklich begleitet und gesagt, da sind jetzt hier schon wieder hunderte von Leuten enteignet worden.
Das ist natürlich eine clevere Strategie, weil sie den Westen bei seinen eigenen Versprechungen packen.
Und sie lügen halt nicht. Sie müssen nicht lügen, sie können einfach zeigen, sie können ein bisschen frameen, aber sie müssen sich keine Sachen aus dem Arsch ziehen, sondern sie gehen einfach hin und sagen, guck mal hier.
Und das endet halt natürlich da, wo es dann um Russland geht. Das ist ja bei Al-Jazeera so ähnlich. Al-Jazeera kannst du eigentlich so lange so halbwegs glauben, wie es nicht gegen irgendwie Leute geht, die mit dem Sultan von Katar verbündet sind. Und bei Russland ist es halt genauso ähnlich. So Russia Today ist halt da überall ganz orkaisch, wo es halt nicht um Berichte aus Russland geht oder wo unmittelbar russische Interessen beruht sind. Weil da ist dann halt vollkommen klar, da gilt dann halt einfach die Parteilinie oder wie auch immer die jetzt gerade heißt.
Gut, aber das ist ja bei uns genauso. Vielleicht nicht ganz genauso, aber...
Naja, wir können uns ja mal ein bisschen angucken, wie das funktioniert. Also was Russia Today tut, ist, dass sie zum einen den drögen russischen Nachrichten-Regierungsapparat aufpeppen, indem sie halt irgendwie da Breaking News draus machen, wenn ein Minister irgendwas sagt und da die Soundbites so rauskratzen, die es halt irgendwie der westliche Nachdenkonsum gewohnt ist, dass also quasi das, was die ja nicht können, also deren Verlautbarungsmechanismus ist ja noch mehr Sowjetstyle. Was RT halt macht, ist, dass halt irgendwie auch Soundbiten zu spitzen, hübsche Infografiken dazu tun, irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das halt nicht mehr gar so unverdaulich ist. Und dabei aber natürlich die für die Russen unangenehmen Details einfach zu verschweigen. Also da reden sie halt einfach gar nicht drüber. Die finden halt einfach überhaupt nicht statt. Das ist halt eine Strategie, die eigentlich so ähnlich auch im Westen funktioniert, wo halt eine Menge Geschichten, die jetzt gerade nicht so gewollt sind oder nicht so in den allgemeinen Konsens passen, wie er denn gerade verordnet wird, dass die halt einfach so mehr oder minder unter den Tisch fallen. Aber interessant daran ist eigentlich, dass der Westen offensichtlich so seine Fähigkeit, diesen Major Consensus Narrative, also die Geschichte, die immer in der Übung bleibt, die Wikipedia-Tagesschau-Realität zu setzen, so ein bisschen verloren hat. Also wir hatten jetzt gerade die Geschichte mit dem Spiegel, wo es jetzt um diese MH17-Geschichte ging, wo der Spiegel halt so tief ins Klo gegriffen hat.
Mit diesem Titel?
Genau, mit diesem irgendwie...
Stoppt Putin!
Von Putin so und wo sie die ganzen Zweifel, die jetzt an dieser MH17 wurde, von russischen Separatisten abgeschossen, Story, die ja begründet sind, also wo jetzt einfach völlig unklar ist, was es eigentlich tatsächlich die Faktenlage ist, weil bisher wurde dieses Wrack nicht von Forensikern untersucht. Bisher sind die Voice-Recorder nicht, die Flugdaten-Recorder nicht ausgewertet und bisher haben nicht alle Seiten ihre Radar-Daten publiziert und ihre Satellitendaten publiziert, aus denen man jetzt irgendwie diese Folgerungen ziehen konnte, sondern es gibt halt da Indizien, die man so interpretieren kann, als wären es tatsächlich irgendwelche russischen Separatisten gewesen oder Leute, die halt irgendwie da sich von der Ukraine abspalten wollen. Aber es kann halt auch komplett anders gewesen sein und diese, dass der Spiegel versucht trotzdem quasi so nach vorne zu springen und halt die Story schon mal festzuzementieren, im Sinne eines, naja, muss man schon sagen, Kriegswunsches irgendwie von einigen Seiten, und dabei keinen Erfolg hat.
Na die haben richtig die Heugabeln rausgeholt, ne?
Ja, aber die haben dabei keinen Erfolg. Ich meine, die haben ja, die sahen sich genötig.
Ja, aber so richtig, sofort war klar, dass sie keinen Erfolg haben. Es hat ja nicht mal irgendwie gedauert, bis da die Welle anliegt.
Am Dienstag oder Mittwoch oder sowas?
Nach drei Stunden haben sie irgendwie das Kommentarding weggemacht, sobald es einfach zu schlimm war.
Dann haben sie ja da ihren...
Und dann haben sie ihre Gegendings da geblockt, was auch so richtig peinlich war.
Dieser Blogpost ging auch so voll in die Hose, wo sie dann schrieben so, ja, wir haben ja unsere Position vertreten, die im Übeligen nur eine leichte Modifikation der Regierungsposition ist.
Und dann ist ja alles gut. Und dann ist ja alles gut.
Entschuldigung. Entspiegel, das Sturmgeschütz der Demokratie rühmt sich damit oder rechtfertigt sich damit, dass er irgendwie die Regierungsposition vertritt.
Die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Aber das ist überall so, ne? Niemand glaubt es mir. Selbst so normale Leute, selbst Leute, die irgendwie mit dem Friseur den zuhörst oder in der Kneipe den zuhörst oder in der Bahn, die nun also wirklich nicht...
Die Deutungshoheit ist einfach weg.
Die Deutungshoheit ist weg, genau.
Und mir ist gerade eingefallen, was ich dann in Amerika nochmal bringen wollte als Beispiel. CNN hat über den Slogan gehabt, the most trusted source in the news. Und das ist so eine Sache, die hat dann auch die Daily Show karikiert. Aber das wäre bei uns völlig undenkbar, dass so jemand kommt und sagt, wie sind hier die vertrauenswürdigen Nachrichten?
Der Rest ist scheiße.
Weil es so zu plump wirkt, einfach sich hinzustellen.
Na ja, die haben sich damals auf eine Umfrage berufen.
Ja, natürlich gab es da irgendeinen. Aber der Punkt ist, wenn du dich hinstellst und rumpralst, dann verlierst du das bisschen Glaubwürdigkeit, was du vorher hattest. Und die Amerikaner erkennen halt dieses, das muss man sich erarbeiten, nicht an der Stelle, sondern die stellen sich halt hin und verlangen einfach, dass die Leute ihnen glauben.
Durch häufige Wiederholung funktioniert das auch.
Ja, das funktioniert ja auch normalerweise. Aber jetzt gibt es halt Medien plötzlich, die in Amerika empfangbar sind. Und das ist ja die nächste spannende Geschichte, was es da für Steine gab, die sich nicht an dieses Spielchen halten. Und Al Jazeera hat viele Jahre lang versucht, in Amerika einen Kabelkanal zu kriegen, einen Kabelfernsehen. Und da muss man wissen, die Amerikaner haben Hunderte von Kabelkanälen. Also das ist gehoben dreistädig. Und über Satellit kann man die natürlich empfangen. Das kannst du ja auch nicht verhindern als Regierung. Denn wenn jemand einen Kanal mietet, dann ist der halt empfangbar. Aber die wollten gern im Kabel sein. Und da gab es dann, sind die jahrelang hingehalten worden. Und dann hieß es irgendwie, ja, aber das ist doch ein Propagandasender. Und so irgendwelche fadenscheinigen, prozeduralen Ausreden gab es dann, warum es jetzt nicht geht. Und am Ende haben die dann einen, so einen Sparten-TV-Sender gekauft, der da irgendwie Dauerwerbesendungen ausgestrahlt hatte, immer damit sie dessen Lizenz übernehmen können. Und da gab es dann einen Anlauf, ob man das nicht verhindern könnte, ob man denen nicht schnell die Lizenz entziehen könnte wegen irgendwelcher Verstöße gegen das Kleingedruckte. Also die Amerikaner haben sofort gemerkt, so dass sie da gerade die Deutungsruhe über die Welt verlieren, wenn sie das zulassen. Und nicht nur über die Welt, sondern auch in ihrem eigenen Land. Und auch Russia Today hat Probleme gehabt, in Amerika empfangbar zu sein. Und schon dass es die BBC gibt, ist, glaube ich, eine relativ neue Sache auch in Amerika. Also überhaupt ausländische Sachen. Wegbereiter waren da die spanessprachigen Stationen für die Einwohner. Aber ursprünglich gab es dann natürlich auch nur CBS, ABC und was weiß ich so, The Big Three oder was, da gab es mehr. Also da gab es zwar viele Kanäle, aber es gab im Grunde nur drei Sender. Der Rest war halt irgendwie so MTV-Scheiß. Aber was ist denn jetzt konkret anders? Was passiert denn jetzt?
Ich denke, dass es mehrere Sachen sind. Zum einen glaubt nach 9-11 niemand mehr so richtig der Regierungslinie. Also 9-11 und der Real-Krieg waren so, denke ich mal, so zwei Punkte zusammen mit der Bankenkrise, die die Glaubwürdigkeit der regierungsamtlichen Positionen des Bestens halt massiv beschädigt haben. Die haben halt einfach zu oft gelogen und haben sich dabei zu oft erwischen lassen.
Wobei das ja kein neues Phänomen ist mit den Lügen. Also ich sag mal Missle Gap, ja, oder die ganze Kissinger Jahre, Nixon. Also die haben immer gelogen, was sich die Balken nur so brauchen. Ja, da eine einzige Lüge. Wie kommt denn das, dass das jetzt plötzlich ein Problem ist?
Ich denke, dass es halt damit zu tun hat, dass der Medienkonsum sich verändert hat. Damals waren es halt nur wenige Kanäle. Heißt, da war es einfacher, einfach durch Dauerfeuer den Menschen konsum des Narrative aufrechtzuerhalten. Mittlerweile ist der Medienkonsum komplett fragmentiert. Heißt, da ist halt hunderte Kabelkanäle, keine Ahnung, zehn relevante News-Sende, 50, 100 relevante Webseiten, die halt irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass sich halt andere Perspektiven etablieren können. Und du hast halt den ganzen Social-Media-Kram. Also das hat schon, muss man schon sagen, dass so Twitter und so haben da halt schon insofern einen Einfluss, als dass die Wahrnehmung von Ereignissen sich verkürzt. Also dass halt der Media-Cycle sehr viel schneller wird. Also mal so eine feste Story zu etablieren, so das, was übrig bleibt. Und wenn du auf der Straße jeden fragst, so dass mehr als die Hälfte davon mit der offiziellen Story zurückkommt, wird halt echt schwierig.
Ich glaube ja, dass die Daily Show da eine wichtige Rolle spielt.
In Amida auf jeden Fall.
Weil die als Erste angefangen haben, mal den aktuellen Äußerungen von Politikern, Archivaufnahmen entgegenzuhalten, was die eigentlich letzte Woche gesagt haben. Und das gab es zwar auch schon länger in Amerika, aber nur in Wahlwerbespots. Und dass die alle lügen, dass die alle lügen, ist ja eh klar. Ja, den vertraut keiner. Aber so dieses Gefühl, dass wir jetzt plötzlich Accountability haben, dass man daran erinnert wird, was man für eine Position betrieben hat. Und wie sich das jetzt, dass man gerade das Gegenteil behauptet, dessen, was man vorgestern behauptet hat, das ist auf der einen Seite gut, auf der anderen Seite versteinert das aber auch die Innenpolitik in den USA, weil sich jetzt niemand mehr leisten will, einen Fehler einzuräumen. Wenn du jetzt einen Fehler einräumst, wird dir das sofort vor die Nase gehalten, weil einfach alle Parteien, irgendwelche Institute beauftragen, sämtliche TV-Sendungen mitzuschneiden und dann da die Clips rauszusuchen, mit denen man am besten mit Schmutz werfen kann, jaja. Und das heißt eben neben Gerrymandering, also dem Anpassen der Regierungslinien der Bezirke, damit die alle entweder klar die Republikaner oder klar die Demokraten gewinnen, gibt es jetzt eben auch noch dieses Instrument der Versteinerung der Positionen in der Politik, weil einfach niemand mehr jetzt Sachen machen kann.
Man kann es konkreter benennen. Also es ist so, dass die Strategie der Republikaner ist es, mehr Demokraten vom Wählen abzuhalten, als sie ihre eigenen Wähler vergraulen. Das ist sogenannte voter disenfranchisement. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass selbst Leute, die halt irgendwie sagen, Obama ist okay, dass die dann halt einfach an die Wählen gehen, weil sie halt irgendwie angekopft sind.
Die Bock nur auf die Scheiße haben.
Und das ist halt tatsächlich eine Strategie. Die Frage dabei ist natürlich schon, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie den Bogen zurück zur Ukraine nehmen, wenn der Westen, also insbesondere halt so NATO und Co, nicht mehr in der Lage sind, quasi eine öffentliche Meinung zu setzen, sind sie dann eigentlich noch in der Lage, Krieg zu führen.
Also ich finde das ja überraschend, muss ich sagen, wie sehr der Eindruck entsteht, dass die überfordert sind, damit Propaganda zu machen. Also nicht nur, dass die Fehler machen, sondern ich habe tatsächlich den Eindruck, die können das gar nicht, die können das gar nicht besser. Und ich glaube, der Westen musste einfach auch nie richtig gute Propaganda machen. Dass Rias funktioniert hat, ist glaube ich ein Fehler, ein Irrtum.
Nee, die nutzten einfach das Attraktivitätsdifferenzial zum Osten, was irgendwie Musik anging. Das war deren Vehikel, deswegen hat es funktioniert. Aber sowas gibt es ja gerade nicht mehr.
Naja, aber das ist ja nicht so, dass auf CNN irgendwie Musik läuft, um den Rest zu transportieren.
Es gibt halt eben kein Transportvehikel mehr.
Ja, aber es ist aber auch so, dass die inhaltlichen Nachrichten überhaupt nicht überzeugen können. Also ich habe einfach den Eindruck, dass ich den ganzen Tag angelogen werde im Fernsehen. Und dieses Gefühl habe ich früher nicht gehabt. Gut, da war ich jetzt auch irgendwie jung und vielleicht beeinflussbarer. Aber also mein Eindruck ist zumindest, dass es richtig offensichtlich geworden ist in den letzten Jahren, dass diese ganze Propaganda scheitert links und rechts. Also sowohl bei uns als auch bei den Russen. Und ich amüsiere mich immer großartig darüber, wenn die Russen es wieder schaffen, irgend so einen Winkel zu finden, um den Westen vorzuführen. Weil ich finde ja, der Westen hat es verdient. Ich würde mich genauso freuen, wenn der Westen es bei den Russen schafft. Aber die versuchen es ja nicht mal. Und das ärgert mich auch wirklich.
Genau, dass der Westen sich nur auf diese, die Lügen ja sowieso Position stellt. Also halt einfach pauschal nicht auf die Argumente eingeht. Aber nicht einen nennen können.
Nicht einen einzigen Punkt, wo sie sagen können, okay, da haben sie aber mal gelogen. Was ja geht. Es ist ja nicht so, als wenn RT nicht auch Fehler macht. Aber dieses Gefühl, dass die alle selber das nicht können.
Ich glaube, es hat mit dieser Selbstherrlichkeit der Geheimnisse zu tun, weil die sind immer noch in diesem Modus, dass sie irgendwie munkel munkel sagen können. Wir haben hier Erkenntnisse.
Und dann aus regierungsnahen, gewöhnlich wohl informierten Quellen wissen wir.
Mittlerweile sagen sie ja offiziell aus Geheimdiensterkenntnissen. Also diese MH17-Nummer. Sagen sie ja, wir haben Geheimdiensterkenntnisse. Waren die Russen? War halt so. Und irgendwie alle so, Entschuldigung zu Geheimdiensterkenntnissen. Kommt da noch was? Die Leute, die uns offensichtlich die letzten Jahre einfach nur angelogen haben, die uns irgendwie in diverse Kriege reingezogen haben ohne dass es irgendwie dann eine sinnvolle Grundlage für gab? Deren Erkenntnissen sollen wir jetzt irgendwie glauben, wenn sie jetzt erzählen, die Russen waren's?
Vor allem gibt es ja gerade jetzt wieder den aktuellen Geheimdienstkollegen in Amerika, der auch richtig schön ist, mit diesen senatsabgehörten Senatscomputern, das war alles.
Na eingebrochen, nicht abgehört.
Genau, aber es ging ja damit los, dass sie irgendwie, dass es hieß, die haben uns hier abgehört und die Daten rausgetragen, aber dann kamen wo aus irgendwie auch gelöscht. Also das Timing ist auch so richtig scheiße.
Erzähl noch mal kurz die Geschichte.
Okay, also die Geschichte ist, die Geschichte ist, es gibt in Amerika wie bei uns ein parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium für Geheimdienste und die haben einen Ausschuss eingerichtet, der die CIA-Foltervorwürfe prüfen sollte. Und die haben in einem Gebäude, was den Geheimdienst gehört, haben die irgendwie so ein paar Räume zugewiesen bekommen und haben da wohl Zugriff auf ein Memo gekriegt, was die Geheimdienste, die ihnen gar nicht hätten geben wollen und das haben die Geheimdienste aber mitgekriegt oder zumindest, das ist jetzt der duktus der Dienste, gerade ein paar übereifrige Mitglieder, Mitarbeiter, sie haben uns sanktioniert, so Year Right, haben sich da Zugang verschafft und haben auf den Rechnern von den Kontrollgremiumsmitarbeitern die inkriminierenden Beweise gelöscht. Allerdings nicht, bevor die nicht ein Backup gezogen hatten, das heißt, es ist nicht funktioniert und die haben gemerkt, dass ihnen plötzlich Beweise fehlen, die sie längst in der Ring gelegt hatten. Also richtig doll peinlich. Und die CIA hat es erst geleugnet. Das ging damit, das ganze Ding ging irgendwie im März oder so los, als die Frau Feinstein, die das Kontrollgremium leitet drüben und ansonsten die Nummer 1 Geheimdienstapologietin ist. In Amerika ausgerechnet die, hat plötzlich eine flammende Rede gehalten im Senat, wie die Geheimdienste damals nicht CIA gesagt. Und deswegen dachten alle, es sei die NSA. Aber wie die Geheimdienste es wagen könnten, auf Computern vom Senat rumzuhacken. Und das war irgendwie damals der Stand. Und jetzt kommt halt raus, es ging um die Folterknastvorwürfe. Also die haben nicht nur irgendwelche Leute gehackt und auch nicht nur im Senat irgendwelche Leute, sondern die haben tatsächlich das Gremium, was für die Aufsicht der Geheimdienste zuständig ist. Mit der Begründung, dass sie ein Dokument haben, was sie nicht haben sollten, was natürlich blödsinn ist. Das Kontrollgremium darf alles haben, das ist ja genau die Idee. So und dieser Skandal blubbert gerade in Amerika rum. Und in so einem Kontext kommen die jetzt mit der MH17-Nummer und sagen, wir haben hier Geheimdiensterkenntnisse, glauben sie uns. Das funktioniert halt nicht. Die Russen sind da wenigstens ehrlich an der Stelle und haben gesagt, hör mal hier, wir haben hier Aufnahmen und da haben wir das und das gesehen. Und jetzt übrigens diese drei Satelliten. Der Amerikaner war zufällig genau dagegen. Die müssen nur mal kurz die Daten rüberrücken, dann ist das alles geklärt.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, dann ist das alles geklärt, sondern Sie haben relativ, also ich meine, gut, ich würde den Russen zutrauen, dass sie schon sorgfältig ihre Bilder zusammengestellt haben. Dann gehen das irgendwie Dinge, die sie nicht so gut aussehen, lassen zufällig fehlen, weil dann leider der Shutter geklemmt hat oder so.
Aber Sie wissen halt, dass die Amis unmöglich ihre Sachen offenlegen werden.
Naja, die Frage ist, wissen Sie das eigentlich? Also warum ist das so? Weil ich meine, die Amis können problemlos, also die Kiwi-Bilder können sie runterrechnen und Digital Globe draufschreiben, damit würde niemand merken.
Das ist übrigens genau auch passiert jetzt. Die Beweise für den Artilleriebeschuss aus Russland in diesem kleinen Gürtel in der Ukraine, da stand genau auf jedem kleinen Bild unten Copyright Digital Globe drunter.
Genau, was sie halt getan haben, sie haben halt einen kommerziellen Satellitenanbieter genommen und die Bilder, die sie offenbar mit ihren eigenen Satelliten hatten, nochmal neu schießen lassen. Oder die halt sowieso schon aus diesen Satelliten, also darf man auch nicht vergessen, dass gerade so viel großflächige Übersichtsaufnahmen sind die Geheimdienste natürlich auch große Kunden bei den kommerziellen Satellitenanbietern. Ja, aber warum sie das nicht gemacht haben, und ich meine, es gibt halt eine Menge Ungereimtheiten. Es gibt halt irgendwie diesen Punkt, dass man hätte wohl, da waren genug Airbags in der Luft, dass sie hätten das Radar sehen müssen. So, wenn es da irgendwelchen Funkverkehr gab, dann hätten sie den sicherlich gehabt. Diese Rakete hätte, wenn, dann eine Rauchschwarde hinterlassen, die man hätte sehen müssen. Also für die es auch genug Augenzeugen gegeben hätte. Gibt diese Geschichte mit den angeblichen Jagdflugzeugen der Ukraine so, wo wiederum auch die Gegenfrage ist, warum haben die Russen noch nicht ihre Radar-Daten über diese Jagdflugzeuge und die Funksprüche von denen released?
Naja, die Russen haben ja gesagt, da sei eine SU-25 der Ukraine gewesen. Also das Problem ist ja auch, dass selbst von den Sachen, wo wir tatsächlich konkrete Ansagen haben, selbst da stellt sich irgendwie mehr als die Hälfte, als kann gar nicht sein. Also diese SU-25, die hat irgendwie eine Diensthöhe von 7000 Metern und es gibt eine in der ukrainischen Armee einen Flugzeug, ja also nicht irgendwie, es gibt einen Flugzeug, was bis zu 10.000 hoch kann, aber nur, wenn man es nicht mit irgendwie Waffen oder Raketen beladen hat. Und dann fliegt es, weil die Luft da dünner ist, nur 400 kmh und so eine Boeing fliegt aber 1000 kmh.
Aber die haben doch noch andere Flugzeuge, die so keine.
Na ja natürlich, aber der Punkt ist, die Russen haben gesagt, dieses Flugzeug haben sie da gesehen. Ja also das heißt, dieses Flugzeug sei genau neben dieser Boeing gewesen und haben quasi so andeut, andeut, also wahrscheinlich hat dieses Flugzeug dann die Boeing abgeschossen. Das war irgendwie, was die Russen da auf den Tisch gelegt hatten. Es ergibt aber überhaupt keinen Sinn eigentlich, diese Story ergibt keinen Sinn. Dann die nächste Frage, wenn es jetzt eine Bug war, das müsste sich klären lassen, welche Bug das war, was da alles für Bugs rumstanden, wem die gerade, wer die operiert hat. Da gibt es natürlich Satellitenbilder, weil das das Nummer 1 Ziel von der NATO ist, wenn da irgendwas losgeht, dann wird als erstes werden da die Luftabwehrstellung plattgehauen. Also das ist mit Sicherheit beiden Seiten bekannt, wo da die Stellungen stehen.
Zumal noch eine interessante Frage ist, ob man nicht eigentlich sogar den Raketenstart auf dem Raketenfühlwarnsystem sehen müsste. Also ich weiß nicht genau, ob der Abgasstrahl heiß genug ist, dass er gesehen wird, aber eigentlich haben sowohl die Russen als auch die Amis Raketenstart-Fühlwarnsysteme, die halt mit hochempfindlichen Infrarot-Detektoren.
Also wir erinnern uns an dieses, Israel hat irgendwann, oder war das letztes Jahr, so einen Raketenstart, einen Test gemacht im Mittelmeer. Und den haben die Russen dann auch angesagt, so völlig aus dem blauen...
Also nichts, wo sie meinten, so Verdacht auf ICBM.
Komisch, da ist gerade eine Rakete gefeuert worden. Also wenn sie das sehen könnten ins Mittelmeer, was ja...
Und die Rakete war auch nicht groß.
Das war keine große Rakete und die Entfernung war nicht weit und sie ging auch nicht hoch. Also wenn sie das sehen können, dann hätten sie auch diese Buchsehen müssen, eigentlich diese Abfangrakete.
Also ich meine, es kann aber unnützige Bedingungen geben, aber das macht keinen Sinn.
So richtigen Sinn ergibt es halt alles nicht. Und was ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann, ist, wie die überhaupt sich hinstellen können und Sachen, einfach Tatsachenbehauptungen machen, die sich innerhalb von einer halben Stunde widerlegen lassen können. Das ist mir so gar nicht klar. Wenn ich irgendwie einen Propagandasender betreiben sollte, dann würde ich doch sehr aufpassen, dass man mir aber auch nicht einen Fehler nachweisen kann, der nicht dann so hell, irgendwie, da hat jemand nicht aufgepasst.
Warum? Das würdest du eigentlich nicht unbedingt tun müssen.
Das wäre mein Anspruch an mich selbst, damit ich sagen kann, wir haben einen perfekten Track-Record.
Aber Black Propaganda funktioniert.
Wir haben noch nie gelogen.
Na, Black Propaganda funktioniert aber eigentlich so, dass du sagst, was interessiert mich für ein Geschwätz von gestern, ob es das Blödsinn hängen, also das Bildzeitungsprinzip halt.
Na gut, aber da hätte ich ja schon ein höheres...
Du, aber...
Du meinst, es ist wurscht, ja. Aber der Punkt ist doch, das war damals im Georgienkrieg schon so, dass die mit den wildesten Ansagen kamen, hier ist irgendwie ein Geschwader aus Jagdflugzeug, Jagdflugzeug ist in unser Territorium eingedrungen und hat das und das bombardiert. Und so wirklich wilde Behauptungen, und dann ist da jemand hingegangen, geguckt, und da ist keine einzige Bombe in die Dinger gegangen. Also diese Art von Lüge, die wirklich sofort in sich selbst implodiert, wenn jemand guckt, die können wir jetzt wieder beobachten bei diesem Ukraine-Konflikt.
Reihenweise.
Und das verstehe ich nicht. Haben die alle keine... Also ich meine, das wäre irgendwie so der Qualitätsanspruch an mich selbst, muss ich sagen. Also so viel Berufsethos und Ehre muss man noch haben.
Ich glaube, dass die nicht in der Lage sind, zentral zu koordinieren. Also zum Beispiel diese...
Du meinst, das ist einfach ein Doofmann, der dann irgendwie... Der Azubi, der gerade...
Also bei den Ukrainern ja. Also was die Ukrainer da so raushauen an Propaganda.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Das ist halt irgendwie da. Dagegen wirkt der RT irgendwie wie Qualitätsfernsehen. Also auch so Detailsachen, so wie zum Beispiel jetzt die Behauptung, die Inspektoren werden tagelang nicht irgendwie in die Absturzstelle bekommen, weil da irgendwie schwere Gefechte toben würden. Irgendwie hat die so links im Fenster die Spiegelmeldung und rechts im Fenster hatte ich irgendwie den Twitter-Feed von einem Journalisten, der meinte, ja, ich bin hier gerade an dieser Absturzstelle. Fotopost, Fotopost. Hier ist niemand, dahinten ist noch der Guy von Reuters. Aber ansonsten ist hier irgendwie nichts zu hören. Die Vögel entzwitschern und irgendwie hat man nichts zu sehen. Keine Separatisten, keine Ukrainer, keine OCE, was sind die Inspektoren? Niemand.
Es gab ein US-Medium, was dann danach berichtet hat, dass sie einen KIA-Fist gehalten worden seien, auf dem Weg zu dem Ding. Also gar nicht von den Separatisten, sondern von den Ukrainer-Sprengern. Mit irgendwelchen Wiesern-Scheiß. Wir konnten ihre Sicherheit nicht garantieren, wenn sie dahingehend und so. Also das ist alles peinlich. Was ja nicht heißt, dass die nicht doch Recht haben können, aber man glaubt denen halt nichts mehr, wenn die ein paar Mal so richtig ins Klo greifen. Das verstehe ich nicht. Also RT ist zumindest, aus meiner Sicht zumindest bemüht. Keine so eine wirklich plumpen Dinge. Na klar, kommt gelegentlich was vor, aber es wirkt nicht so, als wenn sie das einfach billigend in Kauf nehmen, sondern das passiert halt so. Die haben dieses Niveau noch nicht erreicht, wo man sagen kann, also Leute, jetzt ist aber Schluss. Und das ist bei der Ukraine irgendwie bei Tag zwei der Fall gewesen. Also Leute, ich kann überhaupt nichts mehr abnehmen hier. Ihr müsst ja gar nicht veröffentlichen, eure YouTube-Videos, das hat sich ja nicht hier.
Ich meine, wir haben dann interessanterweise bei diesem Propaganda-Ding ja ein paar Sachen gesehen, die, also wo man sagen muss, dass der, also das Wissen um den Einfluss des Medienkrieges schon bedingt, was eigentlich die Handlungen auf dem realen Schlachtfeld sind. Weil letztendlich ist es halt auch so, dass eigentlich allen klar ist, dass was da wirklich passiert ist, also was da sozusagen die physische Realität vor Ort, also das, was wirklich in dieser Sekunde mit diesem Flugzeug passiert ist, als es runterkam, werden wir vermutlich nie wissen.
Erfahren werden wir es nicht.
Nee, wir werden es nicht erfahren.
Aber es gibt Wissen, es gibt Leute, die wissen. Also das ist mein Eindruck, dass eigentlich alle Großmächte und die Ukraine genau wissen, was da passiert ist und sie ringen noch darum, welche Art von Erklärungen sie in die Geschichtsbücher schreiben können.
Genau, ich meine, die interessante Frage ist, wer wird das Rennen darum gewinnen, was in die Geschichtsbücher geschrieben wird?
Na, aber es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt die Wahrheitsfindung ist, sondern die wissen, was passiert ist, aber sind sich einig, dass die Wahrheit nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen darf.
Das Spannende daran ist halt eben, dass die Ukraine offensichtlich auch nicht einheitlich agieren, sondern da gibt es ja irgendwie die Posten wild und quer, mal dieses, mal jenes.
Ja, auch Leute aus irgendwelchen Provinzen, die dann der Hauptregierung widersprechen und so. Also es wirkt alles nicht aus einem Guss. Da sind die Russen echt weiter. Wobei, bei den Russen gibt es auch so ein paar Querschläger.
Die haben diese Social-Media-Posts von den Soldaten.
Oh, feier. Das wird besonders peinlich, weil irgendein Soldat hier bei Instagram so eine Art Live-Feed hochgeladen hat, so alle zehn Sekunden ein Foto und immer schön mit GPS-Koordinaten. Da konnte man halt wunderbar sehen, wie er dann die Grenze in die Ukraine überschritten hat und zurück nach Russland und so. Und er schreibt dann so Sachen wie, ich weiß auch nicht, was ich hier soll. Ich mach jetzt hier einfach Party.
Ohje, ohje.
Na, wie kommt es denn, was unsere Presse da macht? Wie ist denn das zu beurteilen? Also bei Russland kann man ja sagen, okay, die haben ein handfestes eigenes Interesse. Ukraine offensichtlich auch. Welches Interesse haben denn unsere Medien bzw. die USA?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was das deutsche Interesse dabei sein soll. Aber es gibt ja eigentlich kein deutsches Interesse, außer dass wir irgendwie eigentlich irgendwie...
Eine EU-Erweiterung, damit wir dann Absatzmarkt führen. Nee, das ist doch nicht Ukraine. Das lohnt doch nicht. Aber Griechenland hat gelohnt?
Also länger her.
Naja und?
Da war noch jung und blau Eugig.
Ach so, du meinst... Na gut.
Nee, also ich meine strategisch ist es halt so, dass die Ukraine ist halt für Russland eine Pufferzone. Das ist halt so, der Dnieper ist halt so das letzte große geografische Hindernis, wenn du in den Panzer nach Moskau fahren willst. Das heißt also, die Russen haben halt dann ein manifestes Interesse daran, die Ukraine als Pufferzone unter ihrer Kontrolle oder zumindest nicht unter NATO Kontrolle zu haben.
Na und zumindest die Krim, weil da die Flotte steht.
Genau. Die Frage ist halt, ob der Westen das anerkennt und sagt, okay gut, wir müssen halt eine Lösung finden, die zumindest irgendwie die Russen halt soweit beruhigt, dass sie halt irgendwie nicht annehmen, dass halt irgendwie demnächst irgendwie in Donalds eine große NATO-Basis entstehen wird, direkt an ihrer Grenze. Oder ob sie halt irgendwie das sagen so, nee, das dürfen die Russen nicht. Also sozusagen der Westen sagt ja schon immer sehr deutlich, dass sie den Russen ihre Einflusszone nicht zugestehen wollen. Also die Russen sagen ja, wir brauchen sozusagen unsere Einflusszone. Das ist für Russland halt eine strategisch völlig nachvollziehbare Einordnung. Die sagen halt, naja, der Hintergrund ist halt, Russland befindet sich halt in einer Phase der demographischen Kontraktion. Und die müssen halt das, was sie momentan haben, an Macht und an militärischen und ergonomischen Möglichkeiten dafür benutzen, möglichst viel Land unter ihre Kontrolle zu bringen, was sie dann in der Phase der Kontraktion nach und nach auch traden können als Einflusszonen. Und so in der Hoffnung, sich dann irgendwann wieder aufzurappeln. Und der Westen sieht offensichtlich gerade seine Chance, halt Russland nochmal richtig eins mitzugeben, verkennend, dass die Abhängigkeiten, die sich da mittlerweile aufgebaut haben und die strukturen, die da da sind, dass die auch schlecht verstanden werden. Also wenn du dir so anguckst, was so die die Nachrichten über Russland sind, also über Putin, das liest sich halt echt so wie diese Kreml-Astrologie. Ist nur so bunte. Ja, so Kreml-Astrologie.
Ja genau.
Wo du halt irgendwie so, ist halt so. Also diese, diese.
Gab's ja im Westen auch. Auf welcher Seite?
Auf welcher Seite? Steht wer? Auf dem offiziellen 1. Mai Foto und so?
Ich dachte jetzt an den, wie ist der nochmal, der Fett-Typ, der auf welcher Seite? Der ist ein Aktenkoffer? Ist egal. Aber gibt's im Finanzjournalismus auch. Aber so dieses Gefühl ist schon, dass das die ganzen handfesten Nachrichten, so wann habt ihr denn das letzte Mal Nachrichten aus Russland gehört, die nicht irgendwie entweder da werden Schwule verprügelt. Oder die Russen wollen hier Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine führen. So richtig. Wann haben wir denn mal Nachrichten aus Russland gehört? Irgendwie gibt's doch gar nicht.
Na, es gibt schon was, aber du musst halt schon ein bisschen suchen.
Naja, aber so, ich sag jetzt ARD Tagesschau, ja. Wir haben häufiger Nachrichten über Belgien als über Russland.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und eigentlich ist das ja nicht inhaltlich zu rechtfertigen, ja. Finde ich. Aber gut. Wenn mal was kommt, ist das so, das wirkt einfach so. Das bringen wir jetzt nicht, weil das nur Nachricht ist, sondern weil wir mal wieder reinhauen müssen bei Russland. So haben wir lang nicht mehr irgendwie.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass es da nicht gute Gründe für gibt.
Natürlich. Wenn die immer wieder irgendwelche Medien unterdrücken oder so, na klar, muss man...
Wenn man die staatlich geförderte Homophobie geht ja auch mal genau gar nicht. Also das ist halt auch so ein Ding, wo für den Westen an einigen Stellen sehr einfach.
Ist ja nicht so, dass wenn du irgendwie, wie es sich auch in Berlin-Gegenden gibt, wo du verprügelt wirst, wenn du zu tödlich aussiehst.
Ja, aber es ist nichts, was du machst.
Nein, natürlich. Aber ich will mal sagen, so offensichtlich finde ich das jetzt auch nicht.
Na ja, das ist halt schon...
Ist natürlich ein anderes Niveau, wenn da vom Staat betrieben wird. Aber es ist nicht so, als wenn wir da überhaupt nichts zu kehren hätten bei uns selber. Also das finde ich ja mal so ein bisschen doof.
Die Frage dabei ist aber auch, ob der Westen sich nicht überschätzt. Eine interessante Theorie ist ja, dass die Amerikaner gerne so einen kleinen begrenzten Konflikt mit Russland wollen, um eine, ja...
Munitionsabbau.
Nie noch viel krasser, um eine Geschichte zu haben für ihren anstehenden wirtschaftlichen Kollaps. Also, dass sie sozusagen sagen...
Die sind schuld.
Die sind schuld, weil irgendwie wir haben uns in den Krieg getrieben, den wir nicht wollten. Und deswegen können wir jetzt leider, müssen wir leider die Staatsanleihenrückzahlung aussetzen und was sonst noch so alles an Kriegsmaßnahmen geht. Interessant fand ich übrigens, die die FAZ hat doch diese diese Faximilis vom Ausbruch des ersten Weltkriegs aus der Frankfurter Zeitung. Das ist interessant. Das muss man noch mal in die Links tun. Hier hättest du den Blog auf verlinkt. Da war unter anderem beschrieben, was die Österreicher gerade alles getan haben damals beim Kriegsausbruch, was sie alles ausgesetzt haben. Unter anderem halt sind eine ganz lange Liste von Selbstverwaltungen von irgendwelchen Regionen. Die haben halt eigentlich so eine Selbstverwaltung.
Okay, jetzt ist Schluss mit lustig.
Genau, so ist das jetzt bis auf weiteres eingestellt. Irgendwelche Anleihen werden nicht zurückgezahlt. Also einfach mal so alles, was irgendwie lästig ist, wurde gleich so im ersten Edikt zur Kriegseröffnung erstmal irgendwie beiseite geräumt. Das ist ja auch durchaus ein traditionelles Mittel der Politik, dass man so einen Krieg halt benutzt, um sich Lästigkeiten, die sich so aufgestaut haben, die halt loszuwerden.
Wobei das schon fast ein bisschen spät ist in den USA, was da alles bröselt an der infrastruktur.
Der Punkt ist halt, vielleicht ist es halt ja einfach nur der Versuch, halt zu verhindern, dass da im Ende doch die Banker geteert und gefedert werden, die irgendwie den Scheiß zu verantworten haben, indem man es halt irgendwie zumindest, keine Ahnung, ein Drittel der Bevölkerung dafür überzeugt, die halt noch Fox News gucken, dass der böse Russe schuld ist am Collabs oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Und das muss man natürlich tun, solange es an Russland den Leuten noch schlechter geht als bei uns.
Na gut, das wird noch eine Weile der Fall sein, solange die Kohle bei den Orchigereichen landet.
Na, das ist ja in Amerika auch so. Unterschätz nicht, wie schnell das in Amerika bergab geht. Also wir hatten die Meldung aus Detroit, das ist konkret so, dass die Leute eben die Wasserversorgung nicht in der Hand von irgendwelchen wohlmeidenden öffentlichen Instituten ist, sondern das ist alles Kommerz. Und die haben halt gesagt, wenn nicht zu alt, klemmen wir halt das Wasser ab. Und das ist eben relativ großflächig, weil Detroit ist eben Wüste, seit da keine Autos mehr gebaut werden. Und es gab da auch schon ganz andere Meldungen aus der Richtung in Detroit, so dass sie halt in einigen Bezirken eben die Polizei eingestellt haben, weil sie gesagt haben, es lohnt sich nicht mehr, da wohnen nicht mehr genug. Ja, also so.
Die haben noch sogar ganze Fotos planiert.
Ja, ja, also, na ja, nicht planiert, weil das kostet ja Geld. Aber so haben da im Grunde den Service eingestellt. Ja, genau. Und also das ist schon wirklich krass, wie das stellenweise in Amerika gerade bergab geht. Und das meinte ich mit, da muss man gucken, dass man irgendwie nicht die Russen überholt an der Stelle. Denn das Verhältnis der Ungerechtigkeit in Amerika ist ja immer noch dabei, sich zu beschleunigen. Das wird ja immer krasser, wie viel der Anteil der Kohle, der an die Superreichen geht. Und solange das nicht abgestellt wird, ist irgendwann der Moment erreicht, wo es da eben eine Revolution gibt. Und es kann natürlich sein, dass sie das gerne den Russen in die Schuhe schieben wollen.
Oder halt entsprechend mit Hilfe von wir sind jetzt in Kriegmaßnahmen verhindern wollen, indem sie halt dann die Repression hochdrehen können. Beziehungsweise allen, oder zumindest die Hälfte der Leute, die sonst auf den Barrikaden stehen würden, die halt damit pazifizieren, dass sie denen sagen, wir sind jetzt im Krieg, ihr könnt jetzt mal gerade keinen Scheiß machen.
Die freie Presse wird jetzt suspendiert?
Nee, aber ich meine, wenn du anguckst, das ist ja, also wenn man sich so die politische Lage in Amnion anguckt, dann gibt's ja zwei Lager, die halt den aktuellen Statusquo nicht mehr lang angucken wollen. Das eine sind halt die Rechten, die halt irgendwie gerne an der Nase rumzuführen sind, aber irgendwann vielleicht möglicherweise auch die Schnauze voll haben, die halt irgendwie einigermaßen gut bewaffnet sind. Das andere sind halt irgendwie die Linksliberalen, die halt mittlerweile nach Obama jeglicher Hoffnung verloren haben, dass auf normalem Wege noch was zu regeln wäre. So und wenn nur halt eine von beiden, nämlich die Rechten, damit ruhigstellt oder einfriest, dass du sagst, wir haben gerade Krieg, ihr müsst euch jetzt mal patriotisch verhalten, dann hast du möglicherweise gewonnen.
Naja, die andere Seite haben sie ja schon kalt gestellt, indem sie jetzt gerade Marihuana legalisieren.
Stimmt genau. Marihuana Legalisierung.
Ich mein, das ist schon ein Ausmaß an Verzweiflung. Das kann man gar nicht überbewerten an der Stelle. Ich finde das ausgesprochen spannend, dass sie ausgerechnet in so einer Krisenzeit, zumal da wirklich krasse wirtschaftliche Interessen hinterstecken. Also die ganzen Drogenknasties. Ich hab jetzt den genauen Wert nicht im Kopf, aber es waren so was wie 70% der Knastinsassen sitzen wegen irgendwelcher Drogendelegte. Und zwar gar nicht weil das schlimme Drogendelegte waren, sondern weil die so eine Three-Strikes-Regelung haben. Wenn du das dritte Mal erwischt wirst, dann kommst du halt richtig lang in den Knast. Auch wenn das dritte Mal ein Bagatell-Scheiß war. Und so ist es eben, dass da ganz viele wegen Drogendelegten im Knast sitzen. Und das ist eine eigene Industrie. Die bauen dann, machen dann irgendwie Service-Center, Hotlines und bauen irgendwie Stellen, irgendwelche Sklavenarbeit-Scheiße her. Ja, aber da ist richtig Kohle mit verbunden. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt anfängt, das abzudrehen, indem man Marihuana legalisiert, das ist ein gewaltiger Schritt für die einzelnen Bundesländer.
Das gibt schon erheblich Widerstand.
Ja, und da muss man wirklich sagen, dass das überhaupt in zwei, drei Bundesländern jetzt hoch soweit kommen konnte, dass es also in Colorado ist es durch. In einigen anderen gibt es noch diesen Medical-Marihuana-Dings. Da muss man halt irgendwie glaubwürdig simulieren, dass man an irgendwas erkrankt ist und nur Drogen helfen. Aber das sind gewaltige wirtschaftliche Interessen, die ihm entgegenstehen mit einer riesigen Lobby. Und wenn das plötzlich geht...
Hast du wieder die größten Sponsoren?
Na die Tabak- und Alkohol-Leute.
Nee. Die Hersteller von verschreibungspflichtigen Beruhigungsmitteln.
Ja, super.
Die haben am starksten Kohle für die Gegenlobby gespenstert. Weil das nämlich genau der Matte ihnen wegbricht. Weil wenn die Leute kiffen können, dann brauchen sie nicht so viele Beruhigungsmittel.
Na also auch die Alkoholhersteller waren gegen die Legalisierung. Aber gut, ist ja egal.
Gut, also jedenfalls die Amis haben echte Probleme. Möglicherweise ist halt die Fist.
Die Amis sind schon echt verzweifelt. Die haben nicht nur Probleme, sondern man kann wirklich Verzweiflungen ablesen an den Sachen, die sie tun. Nicht nur, dass sie ständig irgendwelche Kriege lostreten. Auch, dass sie da wirklich am Journalieren sind, damit wo sie sich gerade überall engagieren wollen.
Na ja, sie treten ja gerade keine Kriege los. Ich meine, die sind ja gerade aus Irak und Afghanistan im Wesentlichen abgezogen. Na ja, schon im Wesentlichen abgezogen.
Na die haben halt andere Uniformen angekriegt und sind jetzt für Blackwater da.
Na ja, es sind aber deutlich weniger. Also ich meine, die haben halt schon richtig...
Na ja, und sofort fliegt es um die Ohren und man muss nicht fragen, ob man da nicht wieder hingeht.
Na ja, bloß die haben keine Lust mehr.
Ja, natürlich haben die keine Lust mehr. Die haben noch nie Lust gehabt.
Ich denke, was auch eine Rolle spielt, ist möglicherweise, dass die Leute, die damals in dem kalten Krieg sozusagen gewonnenen Anführungszeichen haben und die jetzt irgendwie sich darüber echt ärgern, dass Putin dieses Russland irgendwie wieder zu irgendeinem nennenswerten Faktor gemacht hat, die sind jetzt halt mittlerweile auch in so einem Alter, wo sie noch so eine Runde können, sie halt noch so, und dann ist halt irgendwann Schluss. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das auch eine Menge damit zu tun hat, dass diese Leute jetzt noch mal so eine Runde wollen.
Und noch mal einen Kran lassen.
Ja, und wenn man sich so anguckt, also wie happy befreit geradezu diese ganzen Propagandaleute plötzlich waren, als wieder klar war, ach, der Russe ist wieder der Feind. Da haben wir Handbücher für, jetzt ist wieder in Ordnung. So ist es wieder klar, wo vorne ist. Irgendwie ist eigentlich alles so das Altgewohnte. Wir müssen jetzt nicht mit dieser komplizierten Multi-Polar-Scheiße da, sondern wir haben jetzt wieder ein Feind und dann irgendwie da ist vorne so. Und auch vor allen Dingen bei den Deutschen, also gerade auch bei diesen ganzen Journalisten, diesen ganzen Atlantikbrückeschreibern. Genau da kam es so richtig so raus. So nach dem Motiv, wir haben es ja schon immer gewusst, der Russe ist der Feind. Wir müssen was tun, so was ist so dieses.
Ihr habt mir jetzt 20 Jahre nicht glauben wollen.
Genau.
Ich hab das auch schon immer gesagt.
Genau. Und das ist halt so.
Mit so Ausdrücken wie Putin-Versteher und so.
Genau.
Super, super. Wer immer irgendwie der anderen Seite zuhört, ist an sich schon ein Vergehen.
Genau, Putin-Versteher, ja. Das neue Gutmöchen.
Erklär doch mal, was die Atlantikbrücke ist.
Die Atlantikbrücke ist ein Verein, in dem man aufgenommen wird auf Empfehlung von anderen Mitgliedern, der als seine Aufgabe ist, ansieht, das transatlantische Verständnis zwischen Eliten zu fahren, also explizit den Eliten. Und die Deutschen...
Also gemeint ist nicht Kanada, sondern die USA. Das ist der USA Brown Nosing Verein.
Genau. Und die haben eine erstaunlich große Anzahl Mitglieder und viele davon sind halt so Multiplikatoren, also Journalisten und sonstige Meinungsmacher, aber auch Politiker, ein paar Industrielle. Aber es ist halt schon ein relativ großer Anteil an Journalisten dabei. Und so bis, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist, aber so von der Weile war halt klar, so wenn du da nicht Mitglied wirst, bist du so, dann wirst du sicherlich nicht mehr die Chefredaktion von irgendeinem relevanten Medium schaffen in Deutschland. Du brauchtest halt quasi diesen transatlantischen Ritterschlag für irgendwie die höheren Weinen. Das interessante daran ist, dass die natürlich auch, insbesondere die Snowden-Enthüllungen, massiv unter Druck geraten sind, weil die jetzt schon klar ist, dass sie da halt einfach in diesem Land halt einfach keinen Dienst erwiesen haben, wenn sie da halt einfach so bedingungslos und gehorsam vor den Amis predigen. Und genau diese Leute waren es jetzt, die halt irgendwie so an vorderster Front die Federn geschwungen haben, als es jetzt halt irgendwie aus ihren Schützengraben genau in Russland ging. Und zwar just genau in dem Moment, das glaube ich das spielt für die deutsche Motivation eine Rolle, genau in dem Moment, als der NSA-Skandal in Deutschland den Punkt erreicht hat, wo eigentlich klar war, jetzt müssen langsam eigentlich mal Konsequenzen folgen. Jetzt geht es eigentlich nicht mehr so weiter.
Haben sie händenregend noch was gesucht, wo wir den Amerikanern wieder in irgendeine Krise folgen können?
Genau. Und die Frei-Welt verteidigt werden muss. Und ich glaube, das spielt zumindest für die deutschen Motivationen nicht unerhebliche Rolle, dass, guckt euch um, der NSA-Skandal ist quasi aus den Medien, aus den oberen Schlagzeilen im Wesentlichen verschwunden. Wir reden jetzt nur noch über...
Wir haben jetzt auch wichtige Probleme.
Und das ist halt genau dieser Verdrängungseffekt und dieses, ja, wir müssen die transatlantische Verbundenheit der Freiheit und so weiter. Das hat natürlich auch einen historischen Hintergrund. Da sind halt auch Leute dabei, die halt argumentieren und sagen, so ja, die Amerikaner haben uns halt vor den Russen gerettet. Die waren halt diejenigen, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass wir halt in Freiheit groß werden konnten und irgendwie die Bundesrepublik eine Demokratie ist und es hier so was wie eine freie Presse gibt und so weiter. Was ja auch durchaus stimmt. Das kann man ja nicht anders sagen. Und aus dieser Verbundenheit und aus dieser Dankbarkeit heraus müssen wir halt sozusagen in Bündnistreue zu unserem großen Bruder Jensis Lanteks stehen. Und genau dieselbe Argumentation mit der DDR, die Freundschaft zur Sowjetunion verteidigt wurde. Und zwar exakt dieselbe.
Auch diese Puffer-Zone-Geschichte gab es im Westen natürlich auch. Sie ist nur nicht so genannt worden. Deutschland war der Puffer. Also es ist ja nach dem Kalten Krieg sind ja da Dokumente befreit worden. Das war so geplant, wenn die Russen kommen, dann wird Deutschland radioaktiv verstrahlt, damit die nichts weiterkommen und irgendwie Frankreich angreifen können. Und das war also auch von den Briten. Die Briten waren sogar, wie war das sogar?
Die hatten Atombomben.
Die wollten gern bomben, nicht an der Grenze, in Rhein. Die wollten im Rhein Atombomben vergraben, damit wenn der Russe kommt, man irgendwie so eine letzte Linie hat. Also der Gedanke ist dem Westen keineswegs fremd. Ja, diese Idee, dass wir hier eine Pufferzone brauchen, weil im Kriegsfall wäre das schon nicht schlecht. Ich denke, so muss man auch aus NATO sich diese ständige EU und NATO-Osterweiterung sehen. Das ist natürlich auch eine Pufferzone für uns. Ja, wenn es jetzt zum Krieg kommt, dann wird halt Polen plattgemacht und nicht Deutschland. Das ist, denke, also spricht zwar keiner aus, aber ich denke, das ist durchaus ein Argument aus deutscher Sicht, warum unsere Regierung das okay findet, wenn sich das alles nach Osten ausdehnt.
Ich denke, wir sollten zum Schluss sollten wir noch aus diesem schönen Buch von Lord Arthur Ponsonby 1928 zitieren. Er hat das Buch Falshood und Wartime geschrieben. Und auf Telepolis war da jüngst ein schöner Auszug daraus. Könnt ihr mal gucken, ob ihr die Argumente in der Propaganda der nächsten Wochen wieder erkennt. So, es fängt halt an mit Wir wollen den Krieg nicht. Dann das gegnerische Lager trägt die Verantwortung. Der Führer des Gegners ist ein Teufel. Wir kämpfen für eine gute Sache. Der Gegner kämpft mit unerlaubten Sachen, äh Waffen. Der Gegner begeht mit Absicht Grausamkeiten. Wir machen das nur versehentlich. Unsere Verluste sind gering, die des Gegners sind enorm. Künstler und Intellektuelle unterstützen unsere Sache. Unsere Mission ist heilig. Und wer unsere Berichterstatter in Zweifel zieht, ist ein Verräter. In diesem Sinne, falls ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr noch auf den Flatterknopf drücken. Und dann wünschen wir euch hier noch einen schönen Sommer.